former leader of the SMP at Westminster
Ian Blackford is with us now it's always
great to see you thanks for joining us
on the pleasure to be with you um do we
need a complete overhaul of the system
yes we do because there has to be
transparency and there has to be trust
you know that clip that you just showed
there let me thank Skye and tortoise for
the work that you've both done but when
you've got MPS that are not been open
about where their earnings are coming
from and and of course being a member of
parliament is an important role you've
been put there by the electorate and
they need to know that you're doing your
job so there has to be transparency and
I think it is right that we see
legislation that cleans us up not that
long ago we had the expensive scandal at
Westminster it's important that MPS are
above reproach we've had the situation
of course for Owen Patterson who was
forced out of parliament you've got the
situation where you have had MPS where
you've had paid advocacy these things
can't happen and we need to make it very
clear that politicians need to make sure
that they've got the trusts from the
public for the job that they're doing do
you have a time frame
I think we did do this as quickly as
possible I think what does that mean
well I think that the prime minister's
got to look to bring forward legislation
within this session of parliament it's
an important issue you know we've come
through a situation where obviously
we've had the situation with Boris
Johnson everything that went on with
party Gates the standing of politicians
has suffered over the course of the last
few years so we have to take our own
responsibilities to make sure that we
have our house in order that we have to
be above suspicion that means that we
have to make sure that the rules are
tightened up nobody's saying that that
the things that MPS can't do but it has
to be fair and it has to be
proportionate and the primary
responsibility of any Member of
Parliament is to represent their
constituents I mean you've had a second
job in the past as we know is it
possible for MPS to have second jobs as
well as be an MP I think what we need to
do is actually have rules that the
public can have trust in when I came
into Parliament I had a couple of
non-executive directorships and I gave a
commitment to the 2019 election that
would bring them to close but of course
these were things it didn't have any
interference at all in the job that I
did there was a full-time member to
Parliament but I've chosen that I would
not do that but we need to make sure
that the public can have confidence in
the way that MPS are going around the
business and the primary responsibility
is to represent their concessions and
there are no conflicts of interest
because that's important
why is it the SMP you think that is
taking the lead on this overhaul and not
say labor well I think this has to be an
across party issue because all of us
have a responsibility and I would appeal
to parliamentarians Across the house
let's make sure that we take appropriate
action we need to be sure that we can be
judged by the things that we do in my
plea to colleagues like make sure that
we clean up politics you know we've got
the situation you're talking about
second jobs but there's all sorts of
issues around all party parliamentary
groups that's been raised as well the
fact that there's dark money involved in
many cases too we can't have this so we
need to make sure that we look at all
the mechanisms look at the way the
parliament operates let's make sure that
Parliament is above suspicion and that
we can all take pride and how we go
about the jobs I mean it's just that
we've brought all of this with shortest
media together in one place with an easy
to use tool I mean why has something not
been done before now well I think people
have actually raised this I mean you've
had situations over many years I mean
you've had a number of prime ministers
that have gone in the very recent past
all of a sudden are generating really
quite substantial amounts of money Boris
Johnson's has raised a million pounds
from speaking and giving
exactly so I think we need to look at
someone that's been a politician that
all of a sudden are using the fact that
they've been in high office basically as
a calling card to get paid and so we
need to make sure this is police
properly and we need to make sure that
people can have trust and have faith in
the job that politicians are asked to do
so this whole thing needs looked at the
whole thing needs to look needs to be
reviewed we need legislation to do that
and it should be done on a no party
basis and I'm pleased that the SNP is
the party that's that's brought this
forward everybody else needs to step up
okay what do you say to those that
suggest that Stephen Flynn new job just
showboating no because I think at the
end of the day it's about that
responsibility that we have to the
public skein used tortoise has shown a
light on this politicians have got a
responsibility to act to make sure that
we make sure that we've actually got the
Best in Class politicians people that we
can have faith in nobody's saying that
there aren't circumstances where MPS
have come in and they've had other
interests you know you've got people
that have operated in public services
those that have acted as doctors for
example to give one uh to one case where
they can carry on in doing that they
need to make sure that they keep their
their skills up but we need to make sure
that the the jobs that the politicians
are doing is primarily about that
responsibility to have to the
concessions and they're not Feathering
their own nest that's what this is all
about Stephen Flynn was sat there on
Monday exactly where you are now he's
he's the new leader here at Westminster
I asked him about suggestions that it
had been a coup to unseat you how do you
feel about it okay I'm actually really
looking forward to the job that I've got
now I spent five and a half years as the
SNP Westminster leader I think I had
four Prime Ministers over that period
I've accepted and Euro was the first
Minister's business Ambassador and I'm
getting on with that job I'm also
commissioning a report in a green
industrial future for Scotland which I'm
going to take six months to do so I'm
really looking forward to the rules that
I'm going to be fulfilling and of course
continuing to work as a as a
constituency MP so it's a a new
departure for me using my previous
skills working in business working in
the city to make sure I can Shine the
Light on the future for Scott was it a
coup though look at the end of the day I
took I took the decision to to stand
down we have an annual election for the
the SNP leader I'd been Consulting with
the first Minister about the ways I can
strengthen the argument for Scottish
independence I'm really pleased about
the job that I'm going to be doing I'm
getting on with that making sure I'm
serving my constituents but I want to
make sure that I'm delivering the the
message is how we can Revitalize the
Scottish economy how we can deliver
sustainable economic growth in fact I've
now got the freedom to do that and I
look forward to having those discussions
with you and others over the course of
the coming months well your ultimate
leader is meeting our prime minister
later on today he's heading up to
Scotland does that show that he's
serious about the Union
you know I think there are differences
that of course that we have with with
Rishi sunak but there are times that we
have to work together there are
important things that the first Minister
and the Prime Minister have to discuss
but my message to Rishi is he has to
respect democracy and he has to respect
that there is a mandate for an
independence referendum that the
Scottish government has but whether
that's appropriate let's make sure that
the two governments are working together
will she bring it up with him today I
think the first Minister will use
opportunities as the time arises to make
the case that there is an independence
majority in the Scottish Parliament our
government was elected with the Mandate
in delivering a referendum Richie soon I
should respect that oh well should
should your party respect what the
Supreme Court decided
because at the end of the day what we
want to make sure is that we have a
constitutional way of moving this
forward with respect the right of the
Supreme Court to make that judgment but
this is a political issue and how often
are UK governments going to stand in the
face of the votes of the people of
Scotland let's remember the Tories have
lost every election in Scotland since
1955. this is about the will of the
people it's about the right of the
parliament nobody was saying that the
prime minister in in the UK before
brexit didn't have the right to have the
brexit referendum the European union
accepted through the article 50 process
the right of the UK to leave what is the
mechanism for Scotland to leave the
United Kingdom if it chooses to do so
prime minister has to respect democracy
after just before I let you go there's a
story in a lot of the papers this
morning about Boris Johnson's team
shredding documents ahead of this
investigation into what happened with
party Gay Thoughts on that I think it's
all behavior when he was in office he
didn't mean the office that he had and
of course we've got the investigations
that are still taking place at
Parliament and it should face the
justice of that committee but at the end
of the day I think this is a man that
breached the trust that was put in by
the electorate of the United Kingdom it
was a shameful period for our democracy
it's always great to see you thanks very
much indeed for joining us Mr Blackford
thank you thank you